from the shadow to zorro to batman to
the invisible man
for as long as there have been
mysterious masked characters in
mainstream film and television there
have been actors portraying them
taking that mask off because it's better
for their career if they're more
recognizable in roles and it's easier
for an audience to emotionally connect
with a character with an identifiable
human face
especially in the case of sci-fi fantasy
and superhero characters
the eyes are the window to the soul as
they say
and it's no easy feat to perform with
your eyes hidden and have that soul
still on display
but i think after a long history of
shafting characters in fiction with
hidden features in favor of actor vanity
or audience comprehension i think we've
come to the point where we can and need
to accept that actors who can pull off a
character in a mask are doing a better
and far more complex job than those who
can't i can't feel the air
sucks to be you
because they're taking a bold extra step
to improve the story or their character
wearing a mask when it suits the story
can build strong characters and inform
really interesting and unique
performances from actors
looking back at those who succeeded and
those who were too afraid to try there's
an undeniable art to acting with no face
special thanks to skillshare for
sponsoring this video skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring and creative classes for
anyone who loves learning invest
yourself and your personal growth
skillshare's classes are for creative
and curious people on topics including
illustration design photography video
freelancing and more these classes
include a combination of video lessons
and class projects have a specific skill
you're trying to learn skillshare is the
perfect place to start i was interested
in their film classes by teacher maddie
brown and had a blast watching him
explain tips for creating visually
appealing short indie films the first
thousand of my viewers to sign up using
my special code godzilla mendoza or my
link in the description will get a one
month free trial of skillshare so you
can start exploring your creativity
today now back to the video
the mask problem is not an especially
new one and with the rise of mainstream
cinema based on superhero comics we've
gotten a whole slew of characters with
secret identities running around on
screen telling their identity to just
about anyone who will listen
and as time has gone on these movies
have put less and less emphasis on
secret identities to the point that
barely any characters have them anymore
besides the obvious ones
look at me i'm an anonymous superhero
that needs to protect his identity right
until it would be a big emotional moment
then you gotta see my face and all the
emotions i'm having
and my batman eye makeup will disappear
between shots because i don't want to
look silly
oh no the villain has forcibly removed
the hero's face covering for their final
encounter for maximum dramatic effect
the spider-man films are especially
guilty of that one keep your mask on
keep your mask on keep your mask on keep
your mask on even with their villains
shedding their symbiotic or helmeted
visages as quickly or as often as they
can to give an actor more screen time
than the costume
toby's spider-man twice over made the
concession to heavily damage his mask to
expose more facial features so you can
see what he was feeling which is at
least reminiscent of all the times we
got a teeth-gritting battle damage
spidey with the bottom half of his mask
torn in the comics
but not once did this thing stay on or
intact for the climax of a film maybe in
this particular case it isn't so much
actor vanity as it is the director
thinking it's just more dramatic but the
point still stands that the mask gets
tossed aside
one of the worst offenders of simply
ditching a mask entirely for actor
recognizability is judge dredd
you know judge dredd the character
conceals his face as part of his
government-mandated uniform as a symbol
of his loss of humanity and
individualism as he devoted his entire
life and being to his career as a judge
good old sly stallone wears it in the
opening of the movie gets kicked off the
force and never wears it again well you
know until the ending where he rides off
into the cyberpunk dystopia sunset this
sin was almost repeated with the near
casting of tom cruise as iron man
who argued that they should give him a
totally transparent faceplate so you
could still tell it was him under there
which would have like
ruined the entire aesthetic of the
costume
he doesn't look like a man made of iron
anymore now he looks like tom cruise in
a really tight metal space suit he's
gonna [ __ ] pilot gypsy danger in that
thing however the iron man films were
able to make a reasonable compromise by
showing an internal view of tony's
helmet so you can check in on robert
downey jr's tony stark in a heated
moment of battle but this clever method
of having our helmet cake and eating it
too inevitably became redundant when he
upgraded to a foldable transforming
helmet that disappears and reappears
entirely like dead space 2 or that thing
the guy from friends had in the 90s lost
in space reboot but you didn't think
that would get mentioned in this video
and then everyone got one of those every
member of the avengers somehow
independently developed the exact same
disappearing helmet technology
making it astoundingly generic and
unspecial
and thus begins the new stage where
hollywood will begrudgingly include
these elements of costumes but make them
as formless and easily removable as
possible so they don't have to have the
actors performing in them at length
[ __ ] snake eyes this is the last shot of
the movie [ __ ] you [ __ ] yourself your
[ __ ]
[ __ ] snake eyes doesn't talk actually
i'm henry henry
it's gotten to the point that practical
helmets and masks on set became a
bothersome hindrance and so everyone is
now just standing there naked from the
neck up and miming button presses for
the animators to figure out in post for
turning into a transforming mechanism or
nano machines
son for an industry so reliant on
computer animation to do literally
everything for them now so they don't
have to plan ahead carefully anymore
you'd think they'd hold animation in
higher regard because animated films
make up some of our most formative movie
experiences as kids so many kids watch
these movies over and over and over and
over and over and over and over but i
digress even all three of the spider-man
actors are now mostly wearing animated
masks so they don't have to abruptly cut
to another angle every time they remove
said masks because none of the movies
can be comfortable of him just tucking
the mask into the neck
and so every unmasked spider-man suit is
an entirely different costume from the
masked ones requiring the actors to
change out entirely between shots
just have him tuck it into the neck it's
fine no one cares jesus
oh but you gotta have the face shell in
there it's gotta be this big plastic
helmet all of this is ultimately for the
sake of convenience for the costume
department having to no longer build
comfortable and form-fitting headwear
and actors not having to breathe through
a layer of spandex or cold hard steel
all day
and many actors don't necessarily want
the hassle of having their most powerful
acting tool taken away from them
an emotive face can be a really powerful
driving force and creating a bond
between the audience and a character
tight close-ups build intimacy and
familiarity removing that from an
actor's toolbox makes their job much
harder which is just another reason
voice actors deserve more respect and
credibility for doing so much without
being seen in any way
but let's keep that same energy going
for body actors
this is not to say that no actor is
brave enough to take on the daunting
task of connecting with an audience
while remaining mysterious and
physically indescribable
body actors do double the work for five
percent of the credits they're acting on
hard mode we're talking about the guys
behind the mask like the great kevin
peter hall who had to make the predator
seem agile and mobile in the jungle
while wearing pounds of rubber latex
armor equipment and a big animatronic
monster head but there was also a lot of
thought into
what kind of movement would kind of uh
planet he came from the inner things
that are going on in the character just
like as you would in any character in
the suit or out of the suit that [ __ ]
wasn't easy there is a history of
talented performers who worked through
that fog to become memorable and lovable
characters without an identifiable human
face and have portrayed characters that
we see as frightening
authoritative
lovable
otherworldly yet somehow familiarly
human
and even tragic and sinister
star wars is the only mainstream western
franchise that consistently boasts
characters and masks that are impossible
to remove be it because it's a life
support system a religious symbol or
their literal face because they're an
alien or a robot
and for that i tip my helmet to the
lucasfilm for understanding that in
spite of their lack of human and emotive
faces these are all extremely well
developed and much beloved characters
let's take it all the way back to dave
proust disappearing into his role darth
vader is such a dominating and
intimidating presence props towered over
every other actor on set and his stone
solid skull-like black mask gave him
this almost demonic visage that just
told everyone in the room not to [ __ ]
with that guy
when they did are giving you
clairvoyance enough to find the rebels
hidden fort
i find your lack of faith disturbing it
didn't matter that we couldn't see
vader's face and enhanced his character
by further proving the point that he had
lost his humanity and become a machine
to serve the ideals of his fascist
empire he was frightening and powerful
and closed off to us as an audience in a
meaningful way
the helmet was his shackle to life and
his master that treated him like a dog
and in his most character defining
moment in the original trilogy we don't
need to see his eyes or hear his voice
to feel his conflict through that solid
helmet we could still see that this
character was struggling with the
decision of throwing his life's work
away and betraying the man he swore an
oath to
or letting his only son in the galaxy's
only hope die before his eyes people
don't remember darth vader for the
kindly old man that his force ghost
appeared as they remember the mask and
they felt a lot of emotions towards that
mask
dave prouse's athletic build and
talented body acting brought vader to
life as more than just a cool costume
the guy under it was cool too and this
was bolstered by james earl jones
talented voice acting giving him a
commanding and chilling voice come on
now tear this ship apart until you found
those plans and bring me the passengers
i want them
they could also be benevolent and tragic
in the right moment
it is too late for me son
these two actors made this character an
icon and one of the greatest villains in
cinema without being seen once
and all that work they did makes it all
the more gut-wrenching when we say
goodbye to vader's character and seem
unmasked for the first time
and you know what sometimes a mask
doesn't need to cover your entire face
to inform a character just enough of it
that it starts to mean something
judgment time
carl urban bit the futuristic smart
bullet and wore his helmet for the
entire filming of dread
showing up even the great stallone by
bringing a more faithful adaptation of
joe dredd to the screen
all we see of him is this frowny mouth
that just tells you that this guy is
about to kick your ass and has had
enough of whatever it is you're doing
and in an odd way all he needed was his
mouth alone to convey a lot of intensity
in this character you can always tell
what he's feeling from these little
micro changes in his expression little
twitches and shifts in the corners of
his mouth to fill in the blanks left by
his eyes and brow but shielding the top
half of dred's face gives him a sort of
detached and robotic feel you see enough
to know he's human but that visor is
authoritative and emotionless like a
giant pair of aviator sunglasses it
commands respect and serves to make it
more intimidating to the criminal
element while also yes showing that he's
not just a man his face is his devotion
to his ideals and the system that
governs this society
his face is everything he believes in
when you look at him you know
and that's a lot more interesting than
if he was just bones from star trek in a
big puffy black vest now isn't it that
character is a lot more unique now than
the stallone version bungling around
with rob schneider as his comic relief
bravo mr urban
though for being fair judge dredd's
helmet is really comfortable and easy to
wear all day it feels like sunglasses
basically yeah i could just i could
leave this on like all the time
not every masked character has to be
intimidating either for some it can be a
way to make that character seem really
noble and dignified with their helmets
signifying a strength and dedication to
a cause or just that they're really
reserved
and the tension surrounding something as
simple as a character never taking their
helmet off can be really compelling
like the mandalorian
some of the most exciting drama in the
show comes from din jaron keeping his
helmet on all the time
he only takes it off at the moment when
it is absolutely the most dramatically
interesting and impactful and never a
moment before
these long stretches of hours and hours
of run time without seeing him build to
incredible emotional payoffs
like for example sharing an intimate
bonding moment with a droid he once felt
contempt and prejudiced towards this is
character development happening there's
also the personally devastating moment
when his face is seen by two humans for
the first time ever while he is
desperately trying to save his adopted
son he makes this major personal
sacrifice that destroys his self-image
and his standing within his own culture
for the person he loves most and this is
a really unique and powerful moment that
would have been completely undercut by
allowing the audience to seem unmasked
semi-frequently for dialogue scenes a
character with an inhuman face doesn't
necessarily need to even be a mysterious
tough guy hiding his emotions either a
character like c-3po is energetic
sarcastic cowardly and very emotional
his eyes are designed to always look a
little surprised and his body motions
are jerky and quick and in spite of his
emotionless face he's still a really
iconic character that works perfectly as
a comic relief and a foil to the tougher
heroes surrounding him his facial
expression never changes but he can
still be a very friendly and inviting
looking character with a lot of
expression go that way
you'll be malfunctioning within a day
you know is scrap pile
a talented enough actor can even appear
more than human through a mask
kane hotter's jason voorhees is menacing
and terrifying
without saying a single word of dialogue
his body language paints the picture of
a malicious force of nature that is
bursting at the seams with bloodlust i
thought when jason is staring at someone
and not moving he looks like a mannequin
so i said what can i do
to still do that same stare but add life
to the character i came up with the the
breathing thing so instead of this
you see
this
to me that made it look like the
character was about to spring any moment
hotter's jason voorhees has such a
specific movement he doesn't feel
robotic but is still very driven and
calculated in every decision behind his
movement he has this goal and he's
locked into it for eternity he shrugs
off pain and agony while in pursuit of
his revenge and you just can't help but
wonder if this hulking beast
really is just [ __ ] unstoppable the
way it was written in the script was
she makes the light start moving and it
swings and hits me in the chest
and i tumble down the stairs i said
that's not too bad but
how cool would it be if that thing just
swings and hits me right in the face
in the mask and then i just fall back
like a tree and i go through the stairs
i think it's more in character
of jason
tumbling down the stairs i think kind of
looks too human you get so much without
a single line of dialogue and that's
impressive when you have a real actor
behind these prosthetics and and makeup
it makes such a difference you can tell
when it's somebody's just going through
the motions and when it's a character
but say
what if your character is something
otherworldly and quite unlike anything
human at all
masks that accentuate human features can
be transformative and allow actors to
play characters that don't resemble
humans but are equally as expressive and
full of life sometimes it's not just a
helmet that can be difficult to act
through but a mask that becomes an
entirely new face
doug jones has made a wonderful career
out of using his unusually thin
proportions to slide into the personas
of fantastical and sometimes scary
creatures
every creature that he plays has a
unique walk body language personality
and biology that he portrays while
comfortably coded in hyper realistic
makeup and prosthetics that truly
transform him into something
well anything but a normal man and even
as alien as these characters are he's
able to play characters like abe sapien
or the amphibian man as like friendly
and lovable with their own identifiable
ways of communicating emotions that are
foreign to us but still distinguishable
enough to understand their inner
thoughts
and not all masks are practical in the
same sense
andy serkis and many other actors have
given life to heroes and villains
through a digital mask
capturing the movements of their body
and face and then projecting that onto a
beautifully rendered photorealistic
animated character having to put
yourself in the moment of your character
in the reality of the story while in
this uncomfortable suit and covered in
dots is no easy accomplishment and any
thespian that can deliver a believable
performance through it all should be
given a lot of praise
i can't help but think about all these
brilliantly acted characters and then
think about the halo tv show in a
post-mandalorian world something like
this feels inexcusable because it goes
so far against the core appeal of a
character like master chief
chief isn't initially a deep character
in this game sleep well
no thanks to your driving yes his voice
is monotone and non-distinct but tough
his real name is generic and he doesn't
speak much because he's not meant to be
a character at first
he's more of a humanoid vehicle for the
player to experience this world and the
story of this brutal science fantasy war
between humanity and various alien races
but his lack of character becomes his
character he's a product of a military
that kidnapped children and conditioned
them to be warriors without emotion that
will follow orders without question and
chief being the strongest of them all it
stands to reason that he'd be the one
with the least humanity
but throughout these games we seem to
develop a strong bond with his ai
companion cortana who in a sense is also
a machine designed for war that wishes
to be more than human
the two of them grow closer and become
friends and master chief allows himself
to act out of emotion for her and go
against orders to protect her master
chief finds his humanity for cortana
because of his love for her but
apparently all that wasn't enough and
the producers at paramount's live-action
halo series felt that this story arc
just
wouldn't work unless you could see the
man under the mask
this is where the growing pains of
translating that to a non-interactive
medium come into play it's one thing to
connect with chief while we control his
every action and see through his eyes in
a sense we're inside the helmet with him
but that doesn't gel with a television
setting unless they film the whole thing
like hardcore henry
we have to be outside the helmet now and
watch his actions played out by someone
else and that creates an uncertainty
with the strength of the character and
the people producing the show in fact
the siri seems almost afraid to let him
put the helmet on
after two straight episodes with it
pretty much always off they have this
slow dramatic shot of him putting on
like finally master chief is here and he
instantly takes it off the next scene
they didn't even make it like 20
straight seconds why do you need a
shovel chief might as well use your
helmet over there to dig you're not
using it for anything else it's gotten
to the point that they have to actively
write excuses for him to put it on
because it's such a non-entity can you
show me what the house used to look like
i can interpolate and recreate a
realistic facsimile of the environment
inside your heads-up display
and they have so little faith in pablo
schreiber's ability to act through the
suit that they have not one but two
internal views of the helmet to keep
tabs on him
it'd be less of an issue if this show
wasn't so tell don't show in general
just long drawn out dialogue scenes no
action and characters spelling things
out for the audience that we would be
able to understand by just watching dr
halsey designed everything to her
specifications when her creations behave
in unexpected ways she gets
uncomfortable to dr halsey human beings
are messy irrational chaotic halsey is
different she sees the world as a set of
data to be optimized regardless of the
short-term pain next to this level of
dedication the rest of us ultimately
fall short
like yes i i know what her character is
you don't need to verbally explain it i
can see all that why why are you telling
me this after four episodes i get it the
helmet issue in halo is sort of
emblematic of the show's problems as a
whole they took the easiest route
possible for explaining the characters
and that included losing the iconography
of chief's armored face the dialogue
isn't subtle the acting isn't subtle
nothing is subtle and yet somehow the
show is really slow burn and
downplayed and like nothing is happening
maybe it gets better later in the season
i i don't know i'll have to see but so
far it's just
i feel like if i don't clarify i'll be
battling the comments about halo forever
no i don't think the show needs to be
mindless dumbed down action and be
exactly like the games and i don't think
the show is bad for trying to really
establish its characters i admire the
effort actually but contrary to popular
belief slow pacing is not 100 percent
tantamount to strong character
development characters sitting around
for 10 minute long scenes vocally
describing their own backstories and
each other's personalities isn't
exciting pacing especially in a sci-fi
action series about a super soldier
fighting aliens you can develop
characters while also having action
scenes in a series and if you really
know what you're doing you can use the
action scenes themselves to strengthen
that character development instead of
just stopping dead for mindless action
for the sake of it
it's not this all or nothing mentality
so i don't want to hear anyone saying
i'm being too hard on the show for being
pretty dull
and trying to make master chief more
relatable and human they've alienated
his biggest fans and created a version
of him that they can't really connect
with the same way
his lack of distinct physical appearance
made us able to project ourselves into
his mask and focus on his words and
actions
it allowed us to empathize with him
because we wanted to see a little of
ourselves under that golden visor
to strip that away is to make him just
another generic action hero space marine
guy with a beard
and that's not to say pablo schreiber
does a bad job i think he plays this
version of the character very well
actually
but it's not the same character if he
was to take his helmet off at all it
should have been a much later and more
pivotal moment than gaining the trust of
one civilian
i mean i get what they were going for
with this scene but just
too much too soon
it would have been challenging but it
wouldn't have been impossible we've seen
it before a character with a helmet can
and should work in a tv show tv master
chief's journey to being more human is
lessened by making him more human to
begin with he has a lot less ground to
cover than the character he was inspired
by
masks are worn by characters for reasons
beyond just the practical they can
enhance characters they can have meaning
they can transform them into something
that can only exist in the world of
fiction and in some ways that can be
just as identifiable and relatable as a
human face
no matter who plays him spider-man will
always look like spider-man because that
strange bug-eyed set of goggles inset to
a spandex balaclava is expressive
relatable lovable and recognizable too
some actors can play into this a little
andrew garfield in particular definitely
seems comfortable in his mask his body
language and expressions project through
his costume really well but no matter
what peter parker looks like under there
he's still a hero and an inspiration for
a lot of people he doesn't have to take
the mask off for us to love him or
understand him and if he did it less it
would probably make the moments when he
does a lot more special and impactful
hell just look at the new batman where
he wears his mask more often than he
doesn't and almost all of his acting is
in his eyes alone
robert pattinson really nailed it here i
can't believe it took us this long for a
bruce wayne to batman ratio to flip but
i'm glad it happened as we've seen time
and time again a character doesn't have
to look like an attractive human
hollywood actor to be something
audiences connect with a strong
performance can shine through because
while humanity and personality are
conveyed easiest through the human face
these can be conveyed just as
efficiently through even the most subtle
or most exaggerated movements of the
body acting through a mask forces actors
to think outside the box and try to be
their characters in every molecule of
their bodies not just their expressions
and words maybe it's time hollywood let
go of the limiting idea that a viewer
can't find someone engaging unless they
look just like you and me to be
relatable and likable
it misses the power of fiction they can
look like anything they can be
anything this isn't at all to say that
showing a character's face for emotional
connection and impact is wrong and needs
to be abandoned
no no not that at all but it doesn't
have to be the only way the human
experience isn't just about facial
expressions and looking good for the
camera
with enough skill and understanding of
their character a performer can blast
past that barrier and make us care about
even the most emotionless and unfamiliar
of faces
you know stan creates the outside and
then unlike the spark you know like the
life that's inside without that you know
you just have
a suit
[Music]
[Music]
you